hi ron i run
ladies ladies
[Applause]
you know what
dinos
out of the way
yeah
oh
my god ambulance a different ambulance
the one i ran into
[Applause]
tom
i couldn't afford enough premium carpet
to get us to the stage i mean it was a
short walk but it was pretty luxurious
right
okay
[Music]
i'm waiting on my arm andy
i'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing and putting him down ronnie
only has three legs
[Music]
how do i get to the stage
get on your feet
[Music]
jerry god gross
oh
jerry
guys
oh god oh i think he might be having a
heart attack what are you serious
oh so much stuff is happening right now
call 9-1-1 okay
just breathe okay you're going to be
fine
no jeez did a dinosaur just fart jerry
get a grip sorry guys
apology not accepted stop talking [ __ ]
i wish i could stop smelling dude
seriously jerry did you eat farts for
lunch tom jerry's having a heart attack
oh no i didn't know that jerry you okay
go go go go go go go go go
yes oh my god that was so hot that was
horrible
oh i'm going to die
i'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
what are you doing tom now is not the
time for criticism how did he do and he
finished his two mile run in 29 minutes
and 43 seconds no
i'm never gonna be a cop
i'm gonna have to be a robber oh come on
hang in there pal i'm gonna drive around
[Music]
eddie
i'm proud of you not because of what you
did which was terrible but because of
what i'm going to be able to get you to
do i guess i'm proud of me thanks man me
too
we have so much work to do
chris
i'm dying
i was dying earlier today
and then i died
now i'm dead i had to cancel a date with
shot a mole my tweet and i really like
her
do you think she'll still like me
not that i'm dead what is this
it's food poisoning
i have it too i did not sleep for one
second last night
and i cracked the bottom of the toilet
bowl god don't say that has anybody
talked to tom i can't even imagine what
that tiny little man must be feeling
like i have voided more than tom's body
weight in the last 12 hours alone
he might have just disappeared off the
earth we need to call him
we must reach out to him
i can't do it
ben
extension 7820
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry i get why you don't want anyone to
know about duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out i'm gonna tell you all of
my secrets oh no that's not necessary i
once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks i didn't actually sell my last car
i just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask when they say two
percent milk i don't know what the other
98 is when i was a baby my head was so
big scientists did experiments on me i
once threw a beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca i'm gonna go
powder my nose
amongst other things
if you know what i mean
is she gonna powder her vagina
leslie
i'm here
we have to go hire a new pr director for
the health department oh my god i'm so
hungover
i've never been this hungover i feel
great i ran 5k this morning
really no i threw up in the shower
my parents make me so mad sometimes just
like the time they couldn't
decide who gets the dog so they just
dropped it off the local synagogue i was
like
oh say what
hold on ron hold that thought just for a
sec
hey honey hey
uh it's your me it's wife
it's leslie uh nope i have very big news
for you oh well my teeth are blue
blueberries are you having a stroke i
just ain't around that my dog's jewish
oh
phone water ben
hello
oh hello
hi
leslie it's dead
hello
you know leslie sounded weird i don't
want to wait for tom i want to walk home
i'll join you i'm always game for a
brisk walk also if i leave you alone i'm
pretty sure you'll die
home is that way
watch out for that fence
okay so now you're sure that everything
is okay you know
down there you're perfectly healthy
that man has the largest penis i have
ever seen
i actually don't even know if you ask
mops forgot to look
i was distracted by the largest penis
i have ever seen
you